comment ça vous voulez vous nous prenons
de la paille dans les caissons pour
isoler en revêtement de chou pour
habiller les murs d'une ossature de
chaînes des matériaux durables et noble
qui plaisent aux charpentiers louis
meyer 2 visant les panneaux et des mises
en finale le jeune homme supervise
l'assemblage de la toiture de cette
école maternelle a priori rien ne le
distingue de ses confrères de travail et
louis est apprenti chez les compagnons
du devoir
une association ouvrière qui forment une
élite dans les métiers manuels savoir
vivre aussi
c'est à dire on vit en communauté dans
des maisons de compagnons ou en fait
tout le monde suit les mêmes règles tout
le monde
après la même manière de penser
l'histoire des compagnons en france est
étroitement liée à celle des cathédrales
c'est sur les chantiers médiévaux que
son nez ils ont prospéré les
compagnonnages c'était un peu une
société secrète
aujourd'hui ça l'est beaucoup moins
c'est à dire à l'époque c'était vraiment
fermée entre eux c'était assez difficile
d'y accéder et en fait on a eu donc les
premières traces écrites du
compagnonnage c'était dans des des
rapports judiciaire en fait où il se
battait dans la rue entre eux wind sera
officiellement compagnon qu'une fois son
tour de france complété en aventures de
2 à 6 ans qu'il mènera deux compagnies
en compagnie au fil des régions de la
france et au delà pressant d'un rituel
donc devenir aspirant donc on aspire à
devenir compagnon à partir duquel on
voit partir de là on fait notre tour de
france qui peut durer environ en moyenne
cinq ans dont un an à l'étranger
et après ces cinq ans donc après avoir
tourné un peu partout en france on veut
tailler un chef-d'oeuvre qu'il mac est
assez complexe souvent qui demande
énormément de rigueur
seuls trois aspirants sur dix y
parviennent
[Applaudissements]
il y a deux ans la cathédrale notre dame
de paris était ravagé par les flammes
c'est le coeur de la ville lumière qui
était meurtri mais aussi les traces de
l'âge d'or du compagnonnage qui
partaient en fumée
louis était alors étudiant bac sciences
mais il cherchait sa voie
on sentait vraiment à puce encore sentir
impuissant moi j'étais bien j'étais pas
devant j'étais pas devant j'étais devant
ma télé mais quand même c'était les
images étaient choquantes quoi c'est
c'était vraiment un travail comme ça
partir en fumée
même la flèche quand les tombes et je
veux me rappelle que c'était c'était
assez c'est assez choquant personnes
c'est à cette époque qu'il découvre les
compagnons du devoir pour les compagnons
en fait c'est un monument qui est super
important parce que justement ça
représente entre guillemets c'est
l'héritage qu'ils ont laissé les anciens
compagnons c'est cdc un travail monstre
c'est ça a été pensé c'était conçu à
l'époque il fallait c'était rentrer
complexe en fait faire une charpente en
même temps pas trop lourde qui pouvait
résister à donc à tout le poids qui
avait su donc le plomb qui était super
lot en fait la restauration de notre
dame aujourd'hui ils en rêvent mais il
ignore si son tour de france lui
permettra de rejoindre les compagnons et
les ouvriers au chevet de notre dame
depuis l' incendie construit cathédrale
aujourd'hui c'est quand même c'est qu'à
minuit passé le chantier du siècle pour
pouvoir retoucher duchesne qui va servir
à la construction d'autres dames c'est
vraiment le rêve de tout charpentier
soit chez les compagnons ou pas toucher
aux chaînes et à son tour pouvoir
s'inscrire dans l'histoire ici marie-eve
bédard radio-canada paris